tamo era officials facing new scrutiny
over a newly declassified email from
Susan Rice Fox News is learning the
former national security adviser sent it
to herself
just hours before president Trump's
inauguration because the White House
Counsel instructed her to do so the
email details how former FBI director
Jim Comey suggested that former
President Obama not share sensitive
information relating to Russia with
incoming national security advisor
Michael Flynn and rice is being
criticized over a resurfaced 2017
interview where she said this I know
nothing about this I was surprised to
see reports from Chairman Yunus on that
account today he said that whatever he
was referring to was a legal lawful
surveillance and that it was potentially
incidental collection one what do you
make of that because I don't imagine
that Susan Rice didn't remember writing
that email to herself on the last day of
the White House right I think the point
that she was trying to make is that she
knew nothing about any investigation any
criminal probe which is what it says in
the memo Dana but you know I think that
at the moment what we're up against is
that people are trying to look for
something here you know to trying to I
think get us all caught up in a Hall of
Mirrors and conspiracy theories even
President Trump can't say what President
Obama or anyone did wrong so you know I
mean it's to me it's like you know he
remember the Hillary Clinton emails
where we went down that hall and
everybody oh this is terrible then it
turns out Hillary Clinton did nothing
wrong but here it's a politically
powerful and I think that's why you see
Republicans on the hill trying to help
the president they've subpoenaed people
now they're saying they have subpoena
powers they will subpoena people there
will be testimony but the reality is
when you get down to it
what is it that this is about I think
it's a it's a big flat nothing that's
what it is okay Jesse why don't you take
that because the Hall of Mirrors
I
got your attention if you could just
take what Juan said and just replace it
with everything the right said for the
last three years you'd have the defense
of Donald Trump that this was nothing
that this was a conspiracy and then it
was all politics and Wan's right except
he got the parties wrong
I mean Susan Rice I almost feel sorry
for cuz he's always left holding the bag
right remember Susan Rice was sent out
to explain that Benghazi was just about
a video protest like here Hillary
Hillary send out rice to lie to America
and then what does she do she gets
caught in another lie because she was on
TV calling Trump a traitor for three
years and then you find the transcripts
under oath and she said she saw no
evidence of collusion and now she's
caught it a third lie and she says oh
yeah I knew nothing about Michael Flint
because Dana whenever I do something by
the book I always wait a month later and
then write myself an email reminding me
how by the book I did that thing that's
good it's good to file that under by the
book
and buy the book Greg we you also want
people to buy your book but we also want
to talk about this Greg the Democrats
say that this is just for President
Trump to distract from the coronavirus
but wasn't the impeachment a distraction
from the coronavirus yeah exactly in
fact the distraction argument is merely
just a distraction from the distraction
from the distraction from the
distraction that's the Hall of Mirrors
that we've been living for three years I
love the people that have been
predicting this bombshell every night on
other networks - tick tick boom crowd
now it's blown up in their face you turn
over a rock you find another ugly bug it
is the most unfair coverage in history
you had MSNBC in CNN covering in their
minds the greatest crime in the century
and then they find out just like in a
horror film the call
was coming from inside the house it's a
frame job it's an inside job and so they
have to pretend that the three years of
Hall of Mirrors never never happened so
the government framed a guy tried to
ruin his life and certain journalists
journalists don't care but I will say
this I gotta give kudos to some lefty
some progressives Jimmy Dore Glenn
Greenwald Matt tío Matt Taibbi these
guys are a hundred percent progressive
as left as you can get and they're doing
amazing work on behalf of showing what
this charade is and I feel bad about the
things that I've said about tea at IIT
IRB Giambi and Glenn Greenwald for the
last twenty years because I completely
misjudged them because they don't work
on an ideology they see this for what
this is and they're not embracing a team
they're embracing the truth so hats off
to you guys and Victor David Hanson and
Victor David Hanson wrote a piece for
the American conservatives talking about
how it used to be the left that would
get outraged about government overreach
like this and then the tide has turned
Emily I do want to ask you about this
there was breaking news this afternoon
that the Supreme Court has denied the
Democrats House Democrats request for
now on the documents from the Muller
investigation they've been asked the
House Democrats have been asking this
for over a year
Supreme Court says no not right now
you've got to come and try to brief us
by June first but it doesn't sound like
they're inclined to turn over this
material what do you think yeah that's a
strong victory for this administration
I'd like to weigh in actually on if I
may on Susan Rice and that meeting if
that email is to be believed this email
that was memorializing a meeting at the
White House that took place weeks
earlier than the head of the FBI was
concerned about a potential Russian
asset or sharing of classified
information based on an uptick of
communications frequency not based on
content not based on probable cause
classified information was being shared
not even based on reasonable belief do
you realize how low of a standard
that is and why all Americans should be
concerned if that is the standard and
keep in mind that at the time of that
meeting the UK embassy had sent a letter
to that intelligence community and the
incoming NSA general Flynn himself
talking about the predicates that there
was none that the dossier was unverified
that Christopher Steele had zero
credibility and yet everyone sat in that
room and for some reason continued the
investigation by Peter struck it was
leaked to the media to ensure that it
would continue going and if there were
true concerns by the intelligence
community that the incoming NSA was
somehow compromised why wasn't the
President of the United States briefed
there are a lot more questions but I
implore everyone take away the names if
you're political and question is this
okay and Emily the reason why was an
uptick is only one reason because Donald
Trump was elected so you had a
transition and he was supposed to talk
to his counterpart